hey Alex new house what's up to tonight
for technical test was on yes last
weekend second ones on this weekend yes
that's why mr. completely because I was
out of town and while you played a bunch
of it right yeah I did actually it seems
like so first off it feels like
titanfall okay it plays just like you
remember you're gonna be running on
walls you'll be shooting stuff you'd be
using that Titan you know you'll be
blowing stuff up it feels great still
like that that gameplay loop is so good
like they did such a good job the first
time with just you know making it fun to
run around and jump and run on walls and
you're just always running you're always
mobile I love that yeah they were one of
the first sort of first-person shooters
to do the whole mobility is part of like
the battle exactly which then we saw
propagated into the community and I
guess even over watching some yeah I
still think they nailed it better than
anyone else has before a sense I guess
so how does to feel then does it feel
like like a meaningful evolution of that
or is it feel very similar to that it
feels so the core loop is very similar
but it does in certain ways it does feel
very meaningful like they added the
grappling hook which is probably one of
the biggest additions to it and that
once you get the hang of it it feels
like just it feels perfect it fits with
the feel of the movement and jumping
around and stuff so like you can you can
use the grappling hook to essentially
catapult yourself over buildings right
um I feel it doesn't work like you know
again to use overwatch just as a quick
little analogy it doesn't work like
widow-makers where you use it to base
you like teleport somewhere it's more
like planta commander way you can swing
on yeah exactly and it feels slower than
you would expect at first like you will
you'll attach it to a building and then
you will swing under like you literally
swing against the wall right on but they
know but then you can sort of use your
jetpack too while you're hanging from
the wall to like them launch yourself
over it and then just keep going and
it's it feels like a just a great
addition to it the one issue is it's not
constant like you have to select it it's
one of the abilities you select all
right okay right which is actually one
of that was one of like mine and Rob
people Rob handler you also played a lot
of it that was one of the issues we had
with the game is
there's no reason to use any of the
other perks and really it's just that
good yeah it is the groveling Erick is
just the best so what would the other
perks like the hologram stuff yeah
there's a hologram there was a there was
like a sonar beam you could throw it
would like show you know pulsing my
impressions of where people work which
was helpful and stuff but like I why
would you ever sacrifice that that
additional movement it it feels so much
fun to use that thing and like I I
really wish it was just a set part right
about the game like tribes everyone
exactly at Packard yeah yeah and so i
guess like what else feels new about
titanfall to like does it I just were
fresh off having a conversation about
Deus Ex mankind divided which sounded
like a very direct sequel to to the the
one who came of five years ago and does
this feel much different does it I mean
it looks sharp as hell it looks
wonderful that was the map design
anything new there anything new I guess
the Titans are all different now does
that feel meaningful as well um I mean
the the Titans are probably like the new
Titan scourge is that is probably the
most different and that feels playing
with the titan feels very different like
that's that time specifically has sort
of a flamethrower thing where you just
shoot out this there's a line of fire
and then that creates sort of an
environmental trap other meaningful
changes like taking down a Titan is way
different so you remember in the first
game how you could get on top of an
enemy Titan and rodeo it yeah you would
like rip off the panel and then you can
like shoot it a bunch Johnny so you
can't do that anymore what you do
instead is you rip out its the Titans
battery okay causes a little bit of a
little bit of damage but then you pop
off immediately so you can't just keep
rota rodeoing and right you have to get
back on and then if you if you take out
the battery then you can drop a grenade
down that slot okay um and it's not like
an instant killed in I know okay it
takes probably three or four oh right
yeah it takes a lot robust technology
and yeah yeah went back to the like they
got a lot of warranties people saying
like they keep blowing on my time we
gotta figure this one I had yeah um it
didn't feel unbalanced though it was it
was weird like a it I think that the the
Titans to compensate have a little bit
less ability to get people off their
back but there's still electric smoke
but because your honor for such a short
amount
time like it really it doesn't really
affect it as much um I liked you know
doing that and then hopping off and then
grappling right that guy right so that
was fun but yeah it feels very iterative
um there are some good steps the there
are a couple issues I had with it like I
still don't know if it's going to have
good progression like that was like the
progression in the first game was pretty
yeah I guess maybe technical test is not
but maybe the place where you figure
that out because you're just replaying
this route say map over and over again
at Peter what do you think about this
you you did the second take review for
time full 14 gamespot com you enjoyed
that came a lot I did and what do you
what what does this make you feel about
like well you've excited for it yeah
totally I good titanfall is the first
competitive multiplayer shooter that I
felt the urge to play and keep playing
so yes it to hear about the grappling
hook that sounds really interesting
because I I can I can almost imagine in
my head but I feel like there's a lot of
mastery involved which sounds like a
great sort of challenge adding to all
the great things that I enjoyed about
the original game I lamented the lack of
a campaign it didn't really hurt right I
review so much because that's not what
the game was going for but I'm excited
to see what they can do with it and some
of the stuff that Mike has told me and I
think Rob in terms of like because they
went to a preview event and they saw
some of the story and your Titan has
like personality AI and talks back to
you and is very quippy and like that
sounds really entertaining so I mean for
the most part i'm super excited i do
agree with you it sounds like the
grappling hook should be available
across the board if not all the time at
least make a mode where that's a thing
or people can all right choose things on
top of it I want to know is there any a
point was there ever a point where two
Titans were grappling like swung around
buildings and like smacked into each
other well on their tethers no I never
saw that happen but you can use a
grappling hook Isaiah as a weapon so you
only as a pilot though yeah I the pilot
the time is don't have oh yeah but be
cool you can play tetherball like
literally oh yeah keep hitting a Titan
like around a building I'll be fine
sorry what is up with you in bowl games
I love balls oh yeah it's a Metroid
Prime ya know i'm excited for attainable
too i think they did a remarkable job at
the first game it is interesting though
about the single player software like if
they put out a really good single player
like I don't know it's it's maybe
it's such a like an old way of thinking
about games but I'm always a lot more
forgiving of the multiplayer if there's
a campaign there if I feel like I forgot
like if I got like a really good
campaign out of the game then I don't
need you know the sixty dollar purchase
to be this multiplayer game that I play
for 50 hours then like I've just happily
jump in and played 20 hours of it and
jump away again I think at this stage I
don't I can't remember how I felt back
then but now thinking back about
titanfall I don't care that it didn't
have a campaign I did I actually enjoyed
the company multiplayer yeah I think I
hit the sweet point though where it was
like the second week he came out yeah so
people had figured out how to play and
there was still enough people and then
was like it was a bit well I say by the
time you played it wasn't there wasn't
as many people playing probably
difficult again to those already
missions it's about a month okay right
mom ya know but but I just think it
presents an interesting opportunity if
they can capitalize yeah but i think
this the multiplayer if they're building
off the first game is can stand on its
own I feel like tiny feels weird though
it's like one of the only games i can
think of where they went from a
multiplayer only only game to almost
like because we always make jokes about
single-player games shoehorning in
multiplayer yes this is the opposite
nice and I'm really interested to see if
they can pull this off because they are
still such a multiplayer-focused game ya
know but the studio I mean they're guys
bend this to do have that's really
experience that is yeah I mean Vince on
fella made some of the best you know
campaigns and first-person military
games for sure yeah yeah yeah alright so
generally positive there's some people
coming out saying that they weren't
super hot on us I mean there are issues
like everyone used the auto rifle like
right no reason to use anything else
everyone uses a grappling hook there's
no reason to use anything at the same
problem at the first game you like the
pics well it was like once people got
used to nerf in the end I think yeah um
I think there are also some really cool
things like they've restructure the wait
grunts work in the game so okay and hard
point like time falls version of
domination there aren't grunts anymore
alright okay I'm but in their bounty
mode it's sort of like a low fives war
zone where they're like neutral grunts
that any team can kill grow you can do
grunt forming and import eyes yeah yeah
[ __ ] it out it doesn't say this is
airdrop and then just everyone go Stacy
civilians burgers them it's like the
Fremen and do geminis the original dune
game you just see like a band of
friendly I sure I'll just murder you
exactly they're they're just cannon
fodder so you can rack up points right
towards our Titan beautiful yeah at
least I'm always make them like weird
aliens or something these are just like
we're different i must hate ya wearing
green enough weird